[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه ماي ليال اختيار استهلوها بابره
العناوين
للمره الاولى في بلد عربي كاس العالم
انطلق في قطر
[تصفيق]
تركيا
[موسيقى]
الامن الايرانيه يخنقبات بتعزيزات عسكريه
وتحليق للطيران ومنظمات الحقوقيه تحذر من
وضع خطير
سبايدر سبايدر
وروسيا تضع صقلها العسكري في دونباس
[موسيقى]
اذا انطلق المونديال الاول على ارض عربيه
انطلق بعد تحضير وانتظار استمر لمده 12
عاما منذ لحظه اعلان فوز قطر بتنظيم نسخه
2022 مونديال قطر انطلق بافتتاح ضخم حضره
قاده وزعماء عرب وجانب وعدد من نجوم
الرياضه والفن في استاد البيت بمدينه
الخور شمال العاصمه الدوحه استاذ البيت
مستوى من الخيمه التقليديه التي سكنها اهل
الباديه لتبدو الصبغه العربيه واضحه على
الافتتاح الذي جمع المنتخب القطري
المستضيف الذي يشارك لاول مره في تاريخه
بالمونديال ونظيره الاكوادوري القادم من
امريكا اللاتينيه بعد ما غاب في النسختين
الماضيه
[موسيقى]
الى ذلك ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان جميع الوصلات والهيئات والجهات
الحكوميه في المملكه بتقديم اي دعم اضافيه
او تسهيلات تحتاج اليها دوله قطر
2022 في قطر مواجهه الامير محمد بن سلمان
وزير الرياضه الامير عبد العزيز بن تركي
الفيصل بمتابعه هذا الامر
[موسيقى]
اربع ايام
تنضم الينا في الاستديو زميله ليليان
تنوري مقدمه في قسم الرياضه ليلياننا اهلا
وسهلا فيك بالدقيقه حفل الافتتاح اليوم
بمونديال قطر هل كان يعني عند التوقعات
لماذا لم يكن هناك اغنيه رسميه بما اننا
تعودنا وترسخ في الذاكره هذه الاغاني
الرسميه التي تكون عاده في المونديالات
السابقه
هو يعني هي فرحه كبيره كون هذا المونديال
هو ليست بطوله خليجيه او بطوله عربيه هي
بطوله كاس عالم تجمع 32 منتخب مع ملايين
الجماهير تقام للمره الاولى البلد فبي بلد
بالشرق الاوسط للمره الاولى للمره الثانيه
بقاره اسيا هو يعني بهذا هي فرحه همم
واحنا نقول لبعضنا مبروك اولا بحلول هذا
الشهر ثاني
باستضافه هذه البطوله همم البرنامج كان
هناك يعني همم بعض الغموض حول من سيقدم
واكون كان هناك بعض المفاجات الكثيره الذي
اعلن عنها ولكن بالنهايه العربي الوحيد
الذي غنى هو في هذا القبيسي الذي هو همم
مطرب او فنان قطري كما ذكرت ان هي همم
الافتتاح جامعه بين الثقافه القطريه
والثقافه العالميه كان حفل الافتتاح بسيط
ولكن مبهر بالوقت نفسه انه استطاع ان يعبر
حضاره المنطقه الخليجيه والعربيه والتي
جمعت مع الحضارات
الرساله
برساله قبل همم يوم امس انه هذه هي رساله
كره القدم تجمع كل ما يتشتت وكما يتفرق
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن رسائل الانسانيه
رسائل يعني همم جمع جمع بين الشعوب في
بدايه هذا المونديال فلندخل يعني بصلب
المونديال هناك عدد كبير من الاستثناءات
التي لم تكن في المونديال السابقه ما هي
همم ولماذا صحيح همم يعني هي بالبدايه هي
اول كاس عالم همم تكون فيها حكام ست حكام
من النساء هذه هي سابقه هي المره الاولى
التي تقام في الشتاء نظرا للحراره وهذا
بطلب من همم دوله قطر وعمله عليها كثيرا
كي يقنعوا المنتخبات والانديه ان تترك
دورياتها وتاتي الى هذه البطوله في الشتاء
هذه هي ايضا استثناء ايضا هي المره الاولى
التي تقام فيها همم يبنى فيها ملعب من
حاويات همم لانه ده انتهاء هذه البطوله
سعه همم تهدم هذه الحاويات وتذهب وتستعمل
بشيء اخر فيعني هذا الملعب يعتبر كانه غير
موجود بعد همم كاس العالم ايضا اثناء
هؤلاء المره الاولى التي تقام مثلا همم
بالشتاء كما ذكرنا همم بلاد بلد عربي همم
هي المره ايضا الاولى التي
تجمع اكثر 32 او المره الاخيره التي ستكون
فيها 32 منتخب بالنسخه المقبله سيكون فيها
46 منتخب يعني هذه بعض الاستثناءات يمكن
ايضا هناك خمس تبديلات يعني امور فنيه
يعني خمس تبديلات بدل ثلاثه بالمباراه
الواحده هذه اذن هناك الكره الذكيه التي
تساعد الحكام باتخاذ القرارات خاصه
بالتسلل ما الذي يميز هذا المونديال في
قطر في دوله عربيه عن المونديالات السابقه
يعني ما هي ال- ال- التاتش التي ستطبع هذا
المونديال ويكون يعني يعلم عن المجالات
نحن نتمنى طبعا ويكون في لمسه عربيه نتمنى
ان تتمكن المنتخبات العربيه الاربعه ان
تؤدي جيدا وتتاهل الى الدور الثاني لانه
هذا هو حلم كل منتخب عربي يعني المنتخبات
العربيه تعرف جيدا انه مستواها بتطور همم
دائما تطور مستمر ولكن الهدف الان نتمنى
دائما بهذه النسخه ان يتاهل اي منتخب الى
الدوري المصري طبعا هذه امنيات كل العالم
العربي اليوم ان نرى احد المنتخبات في
نهائي كاس العالم على كل حال سنعود معك
لليان بعد الفاصل وخلاف سياقه شكرا لك
وايضا متابعه وتغطيه كل المونديال معك
خلال شكرا لك شكرا
لا يختلف اثنان على نجوميه واسطوريات كل
من الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي والبرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو في عالم كره القدم حتى
وان لم يفوزاء بكاس العالم ولانها قد تكون
الاخيره بشكل كبير لميسي وكريستيانو يفعل
نجمان لتحقيق لقب كاس العالم المقامه
حاليا في دوله قطر وفي حال فشل الارجنتين
والبرتغال في تحقيق هذا الحلم سينظم كل من
ميسي وكريستيانو رونالدو الى كوكب اخرى من
نجوم الكره المستديره ممن لم يحقق كاس
العالم مع منتخباتهم رغم تحقيقهم القبن
كثيره مع اندياتهم والقابا اخرى فرديه على
راسهم اللاعب الهولندي يوهان كرويف الملقب
بالهولندي الطائر الذي استطع نجمه مع نادي
برشلونه واقتنس الكره الذهبيه ثلاث مرات
وكانت كروز قاده قوسين او ادنى من طاقه
اللقى في مونديال عام 1974 لكن منتخب
هولندا خسر النهائي اثنين واحد امام
المانيا الغربيه ان ذلك
الاسبانيه راؤول غونزاليس هو الاخر لم يدق
طعم الفوز بكاس العالم رغم مشاركته في
ثلاث نسخ متتاليه بنهائيات كاس العالم
اعوام 1998 2002 و 2006 وفي نسخه مونديال
2010 التي حقق فيها المنتخب الاسباني لقد
كاس العالم لم يتم استدعاء النجم جونزاليس
من قبل المدرب
وفي انجلترا هناك النجمان مايكل اوبن
وديفيد بيكهام حيث شارك الثنائي مع منتخب
انجلترا في ثلاث نسخ متتاليه بكاس العالم
اعوام
19980,2006 ولم يحقق البطوله وهناك ايضا
الايطاليه روبيرتو باجيو الذي لعب مع
منتخب بلا في ثلاث نهائيات لكاس العالم
وتعتبر نسخه 1994 افضل مشاركه لباجيو
عندما قاد ايطاليا الى النهائي امام
البرازيل وانتهت المباراه بالتعادل السلبي
وتم اللجوء حينها لركلات الترجيح التي
اضاع فيها باجيو ضربه جزاء اهدت اللقب
للبرازيل وهنالك كل من الارجنتيني
الارجنتينيين طبعا باتستوتا وريكل مي
والالماني
وكان البرتغالي لويس فيغو هم ايضا شاركوا
في اكثر من النسخه لكاس العالم لكنهم لم
يستطيعوا تحقيق اللقب
[موسيقى]
جدد الجيش التركي قسمه صباح اليوم على عده
نقاط بمدينه كوباني عين العرب شمال شرقي
سوريا وبحسب مصادر كرديه في القصف هذه
المره كان جويا ومدفعيا وتركز على تله
المطله على مدينه كوباني من الجهه
الجنوبيه للمدينه اضافه الى ثلاث صواريخ
او ثلاثه صواريخ على غربي المدينه وكان
الطائرات الحربيه التركيه والمدفعيه قد
قصفت مواقع كرديه في عده مناطق الشمالي
سوريا وشمال العراق اسفر عن وقوع نحو 31
قتيلا بينهم عدد من المدنيين في عمليه
اشرف عليها وزير الدفاع التركيه خلصي على
كار بنفسه فيما وصفت الاداره ذاتيه
الكرديه بسوريا القذف التركي بالعدوان غير
المبرر مضيفه ان تفجير اسطنبول ما هو
الاثريه لتبريره هجوم انقره على شمال
سوريا بينما شدد وزير خارجيات العراق على
عدم اراضي البلاد مقرا او ممر لتحديد امن
الدول
في هذا السياقه العمليه التي نفذت ضد
اهداف الارهابيه في شمال العراق وشمال
سوريا منذ منتصف ليل هذا المساء تم
التخطيط لها بحساسيه
ولحسن الحظ كما تنفيذها بنجاح
وعن مواقع انطلاق الطائرات الحربيه التي
قصفت كل من شمالي سوريا والعراق فقد
انطلقت من قاعدتي ملطيه وديار بكر
العسكريتين الجويتين واستهدفت 89 نقطه
للمقاتلين الاكراد وفقا للدفاع التركيه
ابرزها مدينه مدن كوباني عين العرب وعين
عيسى والمالكيه والدرباسيه شمال شرقي
سوريا ومن ثم توجه تلك الطائرات لتقصف
مواقع لحزب العمال الكردستاني في جبال
قنديل وسنجر في اقليم كردستان بشمالي
العراق واسفر تلك القارات عن سقوط قتله
وشرحها في صفوف المقاتلين الاكراد اضافه
لعدد من المدنيين وبينهم صحفي وفقا لمصادر
سوريا
بدورها علاقات الولايات المتحده على
الضربات التي شنتها تركيا ضد قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وصفتنا الوضع هناك بالصعب
وداع منسق الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا في
مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض الى
التوقفي عن زعزعه الاستقرار في شمال سوريا
واكد على الالتزام للولايات المتحده
وحرصها لابقاء الحدود السوريه التركيه
امنه مشهرا الى نوع واشنطن ليس لديها اي
معلومات عن الجهه التي نفذته هجوم اسطنبول
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
مسؤولون لينوفو بخانسي
في القاره الافريقيه الرئيس الفرنسي يتهم
روسيا بالتهدميه تهديم افريقيا
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى الموضوع التركي الكردي والقصف
التركي الشمالي سوريا والعراق ينضم الينا
الدكتور بكير اتجان مدير معهد اسطنبول
للفكر اهلا بك دكتور بكير دكتور بعد
عمليات اسطنبول اصبح هناك يعني قناع سائده
بان عمليه شمال سوريا تحديدا اصبحت مقبوله
اكثر عند الاطراف الرافده وسيكونون اقل
اعتراض عليها هل نحن امام بالون اختبار
تركي لكل من الولايات المتحده والروسيه في
هذه العمليه التي انطلقت والتي لا نعلم
اذا كانت محدوده ام طويله
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم يعني هذه العمليه
لا نستطيع ان نقول هي عمليه ااا ضد
التواجد الكردي بالعكس هي عمليه ضد
التواجد الامريكي والدليل على ذلك قبل امس
كانت هناك اييه تصريحات من المسؤولين
الامريكيين بان على الراعيه الامريكيه ترك
المناطق اذا هناك لا يوجد اكراد لا يوجد
سوريين لا يوجد
مجموعه اخرى ولكن الموجودين لانك ساريه
الساحقهم من الامريكيين المواطنين
الامريكيين واا ربما قليلا منهم الاكل لهم
همم مواطنين الروس لان تصريحات التي تاتي
على اللسان روسيا والولايات المتحده
تحديدا بان على رايهم الابتعاد من الحدود
لان سوف تكون قصف اذا همم هؤلاء الذين
قصفوا والذين
اللي موجوده عليها كلها رايه امريكيه
بامتياز بناء على تصريحاتهم وحتى الى
اليوم لا توجد رده فعل ايضا لا من
الولايات المتحده لا من روسيا ولا من
الدول الاوروبيه كما اشرتم قبل التجزان
هذه الضربات كانت موجهه لهم مباشره
والدليل على ذلك ايضا وزير الداخليه عندما
قال هذه التعزيه غير مقبوله ونحن وقدنا
الرساله وسوف
على هذه الرساله واضحه جدا
العمليات التركيه الماضيه كلها بموسميات
مختلفه كانت تحت ثلاثه عناوين الاول هو
منع انشاء كيان همم سياسي تحت حزب العمال
الثاني هو انشاء منطقه امنه الى حدوث 30
كلم والثالث وعدم ايفاء الولايات المتحده
والروس بتعهدات في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي
نحن اليوم امام عمليه بهذا المسمى تحت
المسمى الثالث ردا على عدم الايفاء
بالتعهدات
يعني ما زال الوقت مبكرا ان نقول بان
العمليه جائت بناء على يعني لانهم لم ااه
يلتزموا بالتعهدات التي قدمت من 2019
لانها همم اذا كانت سوف تكون كبيره جدا
والان هذه ضربات همم يعني همم بدائيه
وجديده لماذا لانها كما صرح وزير الدفاع
التركي بانها كانت همم يعني عمليه همم
مماثله
للعمليه التي جاءت للتفجير الاخير في همم
تقسيم اسطنبول
قبل ثلاث اسابيع في مدينه مرسين والتي
راحت ضحيتها يعني الى مخفر الشرطه
المتواجده عن طريق مسيره همم مقدمه من من
طرف الولايات المتحده اللي قسته واخواتها
يعني هذه واضحه ايضا
كلها صناعه امريكيه بامتياز الموقف الروسي
بهذا الملف هو تباعد اقل
وتقارب اكثر مع الجانب السوري اتحدث هنا
بين الترك بين الاتراك وبين سوريا وتحديدا
النظام كيف ستنعكس هذه العمليه على هذا
المسع الروسي في الاشهر الماضيه
يعني استطيع ان اقول بكل صراحه وهذه همم
معلومه 100% وليست تحليل ولا ادعاء الايام
القادمه سوف تفتح باب الجديده
للحوار بين النظام السوري وتركيا همم
قريبا جدا يعني ربما خلال اسبوعين وهناك
همم حوار ولقاء سوف تكون على مستوى
الدبلوماسي الى الان كانت على مستوى
استخبارات والان سوف تكون على مستوى
الدبلوماسي وسوف تفتح بوابه
التي هي كانت مغلقه على الحدود السوريه
التركيه في الاسابيع القادمه ايضا وهذا
يعني بان بدايه علاقه بين النظام السوري
وتركيا
شكرا لك استاذ دكتور ذكي
لن تعترض على هذه القصف شكرا
مشاهدينا ايضا بهذا السياق ينضم الينا عبر
الهاتف من الحسكه سيامد علي مدير المركز
الاعلامي
لوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه استاذ يعني
استاذ سليمان هذه العمليه التي لا نعرف
اذا ستكون محدوده ام انها ستمدات اكثر كيف
تقراون الرد عليها خصوصا ان الرد الاول
كان بان هجوم اسطنبول هو ذريعه للهجوم على
شمال سوريا
مرحبا بك بتساعد على المشاهدين بكل تاكيد
هذه الذريعه هي عنوان هذه الهجمات التي
تقوم بها الدوله التركيه على اراضي
السوريه او مناطق شمال سوريا بشكل خاصيه
التي قامت بها الاستخبارات التركيه طبعا
بعد المحاولات عديده وخاصه بعد 2019
والتصومات التي وقعت تلك الفتره ما بين
القوه الضامنه والقوات سوريا
الا انا استضافات الدوله
العداله والتنميه تبحث عن ثغرات وعن تبحث
عن عن اضواء وقرود خضراء
السوريه
مع الغرب ومعانيين ومع القوه الضاربه
سوريا
يعني هل يمكن ان يذهب بها الى الاخر
الرئيس التركي علاء ابواب الانتخابات
خصوصا انه وضع موضوع الامن القومي في
الواحه
نعم شركه تاكيد هذا التصدير للمشاكل
الداخليه بالدرجه الاولى الى الخارجيه
لاقناع اكبر عدد ممكن من الناخبين الامر
الثاني هو مقبل على الانتخابات الثانيه
وحظ بالعداله لتامين ما يعرف بتمرير
التعديل الدستوري وعلى ابواب الانتخابات
اتى هذا الانفجار لينسف هذا الانفتاح همم
من المستفيد من هذا الموضوع
اي عقل يصدق ان القوه الكرديه سوف تقوم
بهذا التفجير ليس من مصلحه اي جهه كليه
شعب ان كانت عسكريه
كانت قريبه من التفاهم وان كانت تركيا
في القيام في مثل هذا العمل
وطريقه التعامل مع الملف التركي والقضيه
نحن نعلم الاعلام العالم يشهد على ذلك ان
طريقه
الديمقراطيه وجميع قوى الكرديه
القوه الكرديه ان كانت في شمال العراق
العراق
المركز الاعلامي لوحدات حمايه الشعب
حدثتنا من الحسد
[موسيقى]
مدينه مهبدل كرديه في محافظه اذربيجان
الغربيه في ايران تحولت الى ثقنا عسكريه
مع استقدام الامن الايرانيه تعزيزات غير
مسبوقه ومن مهبه ابدا العشرات من
المواطنين في مدينه مهابات خرجوا الى
الشوارع للمشاركه في الاحتجاجات والمطالبه
بتشكيل حكومه جديده قبيل اقتحام القوه
الامنيه الايرانيه للمدينه حيث قامت بنشر
تعزيزات عسكريه واسلحه ثقيله بعد ما حلقت
مروحيات على علو منخفض في سماءها وقامت
باطلاق النار على منازلها وعلى منازل
المواطنين في حسب مقاطع فيديو تم تداولها
عبر من السلطه التواصل الاجتماعي اظهرت
ايضا القوات العسكريه الايرانيه وهي تتجول
بالسيارات في انحاء المدينه بشكل مستمر
حيث وصف المواطنون اجواء المدينه بانها
تشبه اجواء الاحكام العرفيه فن نتابع
راكان
[موسيقى]
طبعا في اشاره الى تدفق الوحدات الخاصه في
الحدث الثوري الايراني باتجاه المدينه وهو
مرد عليه سكان المنطقه بالخروج للشارع
وخلق ملحمه شعبيه اخرى قبلت بقمع دموي من
طرف نظام الايراني دعونا نتابع مشاهدينا
بعد ما يحصل في مهاباد
راكان
[موسيقى]
وائل اليوم الخامس والستون على التوالي
الاحتياجات متواصله في 30 مدينه ايرانيه
فيما تتوالى ردود فعل الشخصيات
التلفزيونيه على قمع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
فقط ودع المذيع والمراسل الرياضي داوود
عبيده هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون الايراني
واعلن تضمنها مع ضحايا الاحتجاجات وقال
بان مساهمه في تغطيه خاصه او في تغطيه
خاصه لمونديال قطر ستكون مستحيله بحجه انه
لا يمكن له ظهور بمظهر المذيعه الرياضيه
المفعم بالحيويه وسط المعاناه التي يعيشها
المواطن الايراني الاضرابات الطلابيه هي
الاخرى تتواصل في نحو 50 جامعه وكليه في
طهران ومدن اخرى التي تشهد اعنف هجوم من
قبل القوات الامنيه الايرانيه والتي راح
ضحيتها احد الطلاب واصيب اخرون واعتقال
للبعض الاخر
[موسيقى]
كما اعتقلت قوات الامن الايرانيه الممثله
هنجاما
خلعت حجابها على الماء في فيديو دعما
لحركه الاحتجاجات حسب ما افادت وسائل
الاعلام الرسميه وافادت وكاله ايرنا بان
غنزاني اعتقلت بتهمه التحريض ودعم
المتظاهرين وكانت الممثله قد اشارت في وقت
سابق لانها استدعيت من قبل القضاء ثم نشرت
فيديو خلعت فيه الحجاب وكتبت قد تكون هذه
الرساله الاخيره واضافت من الان فصاعدا
مهما حدث لي اعلم انني كالعاده مع الشعب
الايراني حتى اخر نفس هذا وكان القضاء
الايراني
مع سبع شخصيات سينمائيه وسياسيه ورياضيه
بسبب نشر محتوى وصفته بالاستفزازي دعاما
لحركه الاحتجاج
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من امستردام يعقوب سعيد الباحث
في الشان الايراني
الرمزيه التي تحيط بهذه المدينه هو الكيان
الاول للاكراد الذي نشا عقب الحرب
العالميه الثانيه بدعم من الاتحاد
السوفيتي اليوم تمرد هذا الكلام بالذات
ماذا يعني بمصار هذه التظاهرات
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهدين قناه العربيه
طبعا هذه المدينه لها رمزيه كما تفضلت
واصبحت بالفعل في هذه الايام كبوسا للنظام
يعني حتى النظام اصبح يستخدم السلاح
الثقيل في مواجهه المحتاجين في مواجهتها
هذا الجيل الصاعد اللي هي متشكل من النساء
وجيل الالفيه الثالثه وطلاب الجامعه هذه
المدينه لها رمزيه لانها تؤكد على اولا
على انه على المستوى الداخلي
اااه
وتستشرف حتى مستقبل ايران لانه دائما كانت
الاحتجاجات محصوره في المركز وكانت ضوء
محصور ايضا لقاء الضوء المحلي والعالمي
محصول على المركز الما هذه المدينه
الكرديه التي خرجت في اهداف واضحه بانه
هدفها واضح من اليوم الاول هو اسقاط
النظام بدعم من الاكراد جميعا سواء
المعارضين بالخارج او او
كشعب كردي في الداخل فهذا الهدف هو اسقاط
النظام وكذلك
من من من من اهميه هذه المدينه والمدن
الكرديه الاخرى بانه اليوم يتبين لنا بان
في حال اسقاط هذا النظام مستقبل المستقبل
الجديد لهذا النظام سوف يكون مختلف تماما
لانه هذه الشعوب هذه القوميات ده يعني
اليوم متواجده وبقوه على ارض الواقع وهي
لديها مطالبها
مطالبها المحليه يعني نسميها رمزياتها
كذلك تاتى من العمق التاريخي اللي تتمتع
بهذه المدينه باعتبارها هي اول مدينه
تشكلت بعد تشكيل الدوله الايرانيه الحديثه
وخرجت لذلك نرى بان الطبيعه التعامل مع
هذه المدينه ايضا همم مختلف وعنيف جدا
الاخرى على كل حال حتى الفرصه اليوم مع
يعني مع ما يحصل هناك ويدعمون هذا المسار
الانفصال شكرا لك استاذ يعقوب سعيد البحث
عن ايراني حدثنا
احتدام القتال في دومباسبت اول شي كان بعد
قيام روسيا بنقل قواتها العسكريه الجيش
الروسي يكثف منها شماته الصاروخيه في شرقي
اوكرانيا بعد الانسحاب ضمن خطه
الاستراتيجيه وتكتيكيه جديده تهدف لتجاوز
الهزائم الاخيره التي تم تسجيلها وفقا ما
نقلت صحيفه وصف الجونه الامريكيه فخارت
منطقه خيرسون شكل الضربه كبيره لموسكو
التي قالت سابقا ان الانسحاب من المنطقه
جاء لدواعي عسكريه وبهدف اخراج نحو 20,000
جندي روسي كانوا في وضع الحرج غير ان
التطورات الحاصله في الميدان كشفت النيه
الحقيقيه التي اعادت نشر الجنود في جبهات
اخرى منها منطقه الشرقيه وفقا ايضا لصحيفه
حيث تشهد المناطق القريبه من دنيا الياس
في منطقه
الشرقيه مدينتي بخموط وافديفكا ضربات
صاروخيه روسيه متفرقه وقصف مدفعي مكث
وتابعوني تطورات الحاصله اكدوا ان
الانسحاب الروسي من خيرسون سيسمح للقوات
الروسيه باعاده تنظيم صفوفها وتعزيز سيطره
على اجزاء من شرق وجنوبي اوكرانيا في
المرحله المقبله
[موسيقى]
قصيره وفتره راحه الاستعاده قوتها قد يطلق
شخص ما على ذلك نهايه للحرب لكن مثل هذه
المهله لن تؤدي الا الى تفاقم الوضع
التركيز المتجدد على جبهه القتال الشرقيه
اكدت روسيا التي تسعى للاستيلاء على منطقه
جمباز باكملها بعد ما اجبرت او اجبرت على
انسحاب بمنطقه كياب وشمال اوكرانيا في وقت
السابق في المرحله المقبله مشاهدينا وفقا
خبراء عسكريين ستكون حاسمه في الدومباس
حيث تتاهب القوه الاوكرانيه لصد الهجمات
الروسيه المحتمله بعد من ضمت قوات من
خيرسون الى المعركه جنبا الى جنب مع حوالي
300,000 رجل جندتهم روسيا مؤخرا بحيث
سيكون الجيش الروسي مجبرا على تحقيق مكاسب
ميدانيه وانشاء خطوط دفاعيه في جومباس بعد
التخلي عن مدينه خرسان لاقامتي مواقع
دفاعيه جديده على الضفه الشرقيه لنهر
النيترو غير ان عامل الطقس وهنا نتحدث عن
فصل الشتاء يمكن ان يجعل ذلك صعبا وسيؤدي
الى اعاقه استخدام المركب المركبات
والطائرات بدون طيار من الجانب الروسيه
فنائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني فلوغيمير
هافري لوز اكد ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد
تصل الى شبه جزيره القرم التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا بحلول عيد الميلاد وتنهي الحرب
بحلول الربيع
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات الميدانيه لا تزال
المعارك متواصله بين الجيش الروسي
والاوكراني في الشرقيه
انا القوات الروسيه لا تزال تواصل القصف
على مدينه باخمود التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الالكتروني
النفاثه وقامت باطلاق صواريخ على المدن
والبلدات القريبه منها
جنه القوات الروسيه ضربات صاروخيه على
منشاه الصناعيه غير محدده مما عطل امداد
123 من المباني
وصف مستشار الرئيس الاوكرانيا المساعي
التي يبذلها الغرب لاقناع اوكرانيا
بالتفاوض مع موسكو بعد السلسله الانتصارات
العسكريه التي حققتها كياف معتبرا انها
اشبه بطلب استسلام للبلاد وقال ميخائيله
بولياك انه عندما تكون زماما المبادره بيد
الاوكرانيين في ساحه القتال يطلب منهم
التفاوض فهذا يوحي ان البلاد التي تستعيد
اراضيها عليها ان تستسلم للبلاد التي
تتعرض للهزيمه وحذر مستشار من ان اي مسار
من هذا القبيل سينطوي على مماطله لكاس
بروسيا الوقت في اثناء ستجرى تدريبات
للقوات التي عبءاتها
وستستحصل على مزيد من الاسلحه وستعزز
مواقع
ينضم الينا من موسكو العقيد المتقاعد من
الجيش السرجي
يعني بالمرحله الماضيه بعد الانسحاب كان
العنوان هو حرب البرد التي تنتجها موسكو
ضد اوكرانيا اليوم الاوكرانيا يتحدثون عن
حرب كسب الوقت الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا هل هذا
فعلا ما يحصل في المرحله المقبله
هذا التقدير لان المعارك تستمر
العمليات الهجوميه للجيش الروسي في
جمهوريه
متواصله والان همم الجهد الرئيسي هو رامي
الى همم
على منطقه
همم وهناك تصريحات همم غريبه عجيبه همم
تاتي يوميا من كيف همم
المشاهدون كلام الان في تقرير هناك وزير
الدفاع المدنيين انا قبل عيد الميلاد همم
سوف همم النصر والحرب تنتهي بالنصر وقراني
هذا امر مستحيل ولا شيء
همم نعم كان هناك نوع من هذه المعسكريه
والسياسيه وديبورماسيه
واعلاميه بدرجه اساس عندما
اتخذت القياده الروسيه بقرار سحب قواتها
من الضفه اليمنى
ودخله القوات الاوكراديه مدينه خرسانه
التي تم اعلانها مركز المحافظه الروسيه
قبل شهر من ذلك اليوم اليوم ولكن ما يجري
حاليا هو اعاده تجميع القوات وكل من الجيش
الروسي والجيش الاوكراني يستعيد بشان
الهجوم همم واسع النساء من الواضح ان همم
رئاسه كان الجيش الاوكرانيه الشبه الرسميه
او الحشد الرئيسي سوف يتركز في اتجاه
مدينه
ومن ثم بعد انجاز المهمه الاولويه سوف يتم
توجيه الضربات على شبه جزيره القرم بقيت
اعاده السيطره عليها بعد هذا معلوم وهذا
ما تاخذه بعد الاعتبار القياده العسكريه
الروسيه لذلك يتم حشد الجهود في جمهوريه
اليسكو وفي همم محافظه جبروجين
روسي واعاده يعني انتشار كما تحدثوا في
الفتره الماضيه عذرا على المقاطعه همم
ساعدت العقيد ولكن مضطر ان انهي شكرا لك
العاقد متقاعد من الجيش سر الجيش
[موسيقى]
ازمه جديده تلوح في الافق بين فرنسا
وروسيا والسبب دول القرن الافريقي حيث
اتهم الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون روسيا
لتغذيه دعايه مناهضه لفرنسا في افريقيا
لخدمه طموحاتها اذا استخدم مكروه عباره ان
روسيا تريد دول افريقيا واتهامها محملا
روسيا سبب فشل التدخل العسكري في مالي
كجزء من عمليه مكافحه الارهاب وبانها كانت
سبب في تراجع النفوذ العسكريه الفرنسي في
المنطقه الافريقيه في اشاره طبعا الى تدخل
مرتزقه في مالي بعد الانقلاب الذي حدث
مؤخرا وقال بان عدد من القوى التابعه
لروسيا والتي تريد نشر النفوذ في افريقيا
تتهم فرنسا باستغلال علاقاتها الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه في مستعمراتها السابقه فقط
للاذاء والاذاء فرنسا والاضرار بها وبان
روسيا تسعى الافتراس الدول الافريقيه
المطربه همم في اشاره الى ان روسيا قامت
بنشر مجموعه مقاولات العسكريه الخاصه فيها
وادي النيروجروب في العديد من البلدان بما
في ذلك جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى ومالي
[موسيقى]
افادت وسائل الاعلام غربيه ان حكومه
الولايات المتحده يمكن ان تطرح تحقيقا
بخصوص استحواذ الى ماسك على منصه تويتر
فوفقا لتقرير صادر عن بلومبيرغ تدرس
الحكومه الامريكيه ما اذا كان شراء ماسك
في الاستثمار او شركاء في الاستثمار
الاجنبي لديهم امكانيات الوصول الى بيانات
المستخدمين الخاصه على المنصه وقالت مصادر
قريبه من الموقف ل- وكاله بلومبرج ان
الحكومه تطلب مزيدا من التفاصيل حول
اتفاقيات ماسك الخاصه مع المستثمرين
الدوليين الذين لديهم حصص في الشركه جاء
هذا في وقت طلب فيها اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
التحقيق في صفقه استحواذ ماسك على منصه
تويتر حيث قالوا بان ماسك انتهك قوانين
حمايه المستهلك واتخذ خطوات مثيره للقلق
قوضات نزاهه وسلامه
ينضم الينا من سان فرانسيسكو مراسل
العربيه حسين الطاطا حسين يعني هناك
الكثير الكثير من الاسئله حول موضوع
التويتر سابدا من استقالات عدد من الفنيين
اليوم انطلق كاس العالم هل ممكن ان تؤثر
على اداء المنصه
تحيه لك ليال هذه اللحظه في الحقيقه هي
لحظه تحدي ما بين الماس من جهه وما بين من
يحذر من ان الموقع تويتر سينهار او قد
ينهار خلال كاس العالم بسبب دخول عدد كبير
من الزوار عددها من الزوار عليه ولكن
منذ ثلاث ساعات تقريبا غرد داعيا الى
متابعه مجريات كاس العالم عبر تويتر في
تحدي منه لهؤلاء الذين يقولون ان همم
المنصقه تقع بسبب نقص طبعا خطوره همم
الاستقالات التي جنت خلال الايام الماضيه
هي ان عددا كبيرا منها هؤلاء هم مهندسون
التقنيون
وفنيون يشرفون على بقاء المنصه تعمل بشكل
انسيابي ويمنعون اي انقطاعات تهدد همم
توقف تويتر الان كاس العالم بدا خلال هذه
الايام سنرى من هو محقق كان لديه خطه
بديله ويعرف ماذا يفعل ام ان الخبراء
الذين كانوا بجزء منهم يعمل داخل تويتر
لديهم معلومات وهم وحقون باننا قد نشهد
تقطع في تويتر خلال الايام القادمه ولكن
هناك ايضا من يقول باننا قد لا نرى انقطاع
كامل لتويتر بشكل المفاجئ ولكن قد يواجه
الزائرون او المستخدمون تويتر مثلا بطءا
في التحميل وفي تحديث وتحديث تايم لاين
وعدد من المشاكل الاخرى كتنزيل الفيديوهات
او مشاهده الفيديوهات عبر المنصه عوده
ترامب الى تويتر بعد استفتاء الذي طرحها
وماسك ترامب بين همم تروس وبين التويتر
اين هو اليوم
حسين هل مازلت تسمعني على ما يبدو اننا
فقدنا الاتصال بالزميل حسين طوط شكرا لك
على هذه الرساله تتابعونا في التاسعه ولكن
بعد قليل
في اقصى الشرق الروسي تحذيرات من اخطر
ثوران للبراكين
[موسيقى]
حد زاره مجموعه من العلماء من تداعيات
ثوران بركانين في شبه جزيره كامتشات
كاروسيه حيث ذكرت تقارير اخباريه ان
الثوران الجديد المفاجئ عقب زلزال قويا
وتسبب في تشكل سحب شاهقه من الرماد والحمم
البركانيه المتوهجه من البركانين وقال
معهد علم البراكين التابعه للاكاديميه
الروسيه بان شبه جزيره كما تشاتكا التي
تمتد الى المحيط الهادئ على بعد حوالي
6600 كيلو متر شرق موسكو هي واحده من اكثر
مناطق العالم تركيزا فيما يتعلق بالنشاط
الحراري الارضي مع وجود حوالي 30 بركانا
نشيطا فيها
توفي شخصان على الاقل نتيجه عاصفه ثلجيه
ضربت غرب ولايه نيويورك في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مؤخرا كما دفع تساقط
الثلوج التي وصلت ارتفاعها الى نحو مترين
بالمسؤولين في الولايه الى فرد مزيد من
قيود السفر على الطرق بالاضافه الى الغاء
شركات الطيران لرحلاتها الجويه في منطقه
بوفالو فيما تدخل نحو 150 عنصرا من الحرس
الوطني للمساعده في ازاله الجليد وتامين
احتياجات السكان في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
في المقاطعه
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
للمره الاولى في بلد عربي كاس العالم
انطلق في قطر
[تصفيق]
تركيا
قصد تهدد بالرد والعراق يدعو للحوار
الامن الايرانيه
العسكريه وتحليق للطيران ومنظمات الحقوقيه
تحذر من وضع خطير
سبايدر مان
التاسعه انتهت مشاهدينا لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما تكون ليلى والان الى 360 مع
زملاء راويه وطاهر راويه وطاهر ماذا لديكم
الليله اهلا بك يا عيال سنتحدث طبعا عن
موديل قطر والافتتاح اليوم وايضا عن
الضربات التركيه على شمال سوريا وايضا
العراق العراق